إن استخدام
الكتاب المقدس كسلاح من قبل المسيحيين الصهيونيين هو
أمر مزعج للغاية بالنسبة لنا، كما
تعلمون بالنسبة لنا، هؤلاء
الصهاينة المسيحيون هم في الواقع
معادون للسامية لأنهم لا يحبون
الشعب اليهودي، ويريدون أن يأتي جميع اليهود
إلى فلسطين وفقًا لذلك.  إلى أيديولوجيتهم القائلة
بأن اثنين وثلاثة سيقتلون في الحرب
والثلث الأخير سيتحول إلى
المسيحية، لذا فهم
يدعون إلى استنشاق
الشعب اليهودي ولكن ليس لدى نتنياهو مشكلة في
مشاركة السرير معهم ليس من باب الحب ولكن
لتحقيق رغبات أنانية.  إذاً أقول وأنا
سعيد للغاية لأنه في الواقع أه نتنياهو
لا يمثل الشعب اليهودي بأكمله، كما تعلمون،
اليهودية واسعة جدًا
مثل المسيحية والإسلام، إنها
ديانة واسعة جدًا لديك من أقصى
اليمين إلى أقصى اليسار ح ومن أجل  أنا أه
مجموعات مثل الأصوات اليهودية من أجل السلام
فهي علامة أمل في الواقع
معًا كيهود مسلمين ومسيحيين
مهتمين بالمساواة
والكرامة الإنسانية والعدالة حتى يتمكن الشعبان من
تقاسم الأرض
ويمكن للأديان الثلاثة العيش جنبًا إلى جنب أنا  أعتقد أن
هذه هي الرؤية التي ندعو
إليها